alright hey what's up I'm Dane Cook I'm
on a tour if you don't know about it
then [ __ ] it
but it's called tell it like it is for
anybody who's interested in actually
getting out and laughing for a little
bit I'm gonna answer some questions he's
gonna handy cards I'll do the best that
I can you have to have some devils
threesomes with one male actor who would
it be
you have to have a devil's threesome
devil's threesome two guys one girl Brad
Pitt do I throw this like what am I used
to make a okay cool what STD would you
be willing to have if you were able to
pass it on to your biggest enemy um
polio was that a STD was that considered
an STD back in the day Gotoh leo which
fictional character would you love to
beat the [ __ ] out of fictional real-life
character or fictional character
probably the guy who wrote me the email
under anonymous at yahoo.com five years
ago if you don't know it google it if
you could go back to any time period who
would you want to go back and party with
I'd probably go back I want to meet
Elvis and but I want to be there like
later you know and he was sweating a lot
and he was I just have that thing where
I love rooting for somebody who is
really on the brink of probably dying
while they're performing what's the
grossest thing you like to eat that you
hide from others out of shame the
grossest thing well you know what I put
ketchup on my pizza yeah yeah like a lot
of it yeah if you had to win a game show
to stay alive which game show would you
choose I would choose The Price is Right
with the wheel and when you spin it it
goes
[Music]
The Witcher rather burped the sound of a
gong or sneeze the sound of a bowling
strike I wouldn't want to sneeze the
[ __ ] bowling strike yeah I don't know
why but that's a great question okay the
one celebrity birthday party you would
want to attend
u2's bono because I'm not really a fan
so I just walk out I just leave
I'd be like Bono I'm out Thanks okay
what's the fiercest animal you think you
Byway youtube fans relax
it's a [ __ ] gag what's the fiercest
animal you think that you could take on
in a fight a wider
no no it's a wider is a whale in a tiger
yeah I made up my own crossbreed I mean
the question was already so [ __ ] okay
would you would you rather never have to
wipe your ass again or never have to
shave again I'd rather have to never
have to shave again because it's coming
like I'm at that age where it's like it
stays dark here I look like Sons of
Anarchy if I grow it for like more than
two days okay if you're born with action
figure hands stuck in the same position
forever what position would both your
hands be it's easy kung fu grip you can
freeze on me right here right
roll roll credits like an 80s 80s sick
up cool man
thank you again guys appreciate it all
right that was a lot of fun